[Applause]
in glasgow we've heard how climate
concern sounds
this is what it looks like
on the fringes of cop 26 where
politicians talk climate solutions the
people walk to the wall
tens of thousands of them
[Music]
a global day of action around the summit
at the host city at its center when we
talk about fossil fuel extraction on our
side of the planet it comes with a lot
of
injustices human rights and justices so
even for me to be here i don't know if
i'll be safe when i go back home listen
to indigenous people indigenous people
are the solution we know the answers
we've known all along we just need to be
included we need to be listened to i
come from the petroleum belt puerto rico
texas we're the heart of it and we see
the damage that's done every day by
petrochemical fuels and the
petrochemical expansion
they march through persistent rain
the climate's gentle nudge on a glasgow
day in november
around cop 26 there's been much
criticism of decisions made and the
prospect of delivery
derision
found an echo here
yes we have to give global temperatures
to 1.5 degrees but it still won't be
safe for communities like mine
1.2 degrees is already held for us it's
already destruction it's already
suffering it's already disaster
we've already had a youth demonstration
through glasgow the demographic is
different here this is an international
crowd with diverse specific concerns
united by one climate change
away from the main demonstration
protesters locked onto king george v
bridge
before being removed
[Applause]
what happens in glasgow over these two
weeks will shape climate change policy
what happened this weekend was that the
people had their say
loud and clear
hey
james matthews sky news glasgow